it's Congress's turn to pay tribute to
Senator John McCain this morning when he
lies in state at the US Capitol more
than three thousand people including
former a former vice president and an
all-pro wide receiver said farewell at a
memorial service in Phoenix yesterday
McCain was then brought back to
Washington for the last time Nancy
Cordes covered the memorial service in
Arizona she's now on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning John McCain
loved this institution and today the
institution pays its respects to him
when McCain lies in state inside the
Capitol Rotunda he will be just the 35th
person to receive that honor since the
1860s as the plane touched down at
Andrews Air Force Base
defense secretary James Madison John
McCain and his family it was McCain's
final journey from Arizona
[Applause]
where thousands gathered Thursday at the
North Phoenix Baptist Church to pay
their respects
I always thought of John as a brother we
had held a lot of family fights and
woods described the cocky would-be
congressman who hired him to be his
chief of staff in 1983 on my first day
at 7:00 a.m.
John McCain picked me up at my house it
was at the same time just really a lot
of fun and also quite terrifying because
of his ridiculously bad driving McCain's
stubborn streak led to some unorthodox
political moves he says I want you to
co-chair my campaign said well John you
know I'm a Democrat McCain even shared
his straight talk with the Arizona
Cardinals star receiver sometimes it was
just a visit to our practices other
times it was him texting and saying you
need to pick it up to Sunday
a reminder former Vice President Biden
said in these polarized times to put
people before politics or a part company
with you if you lack the basic values of
decency respect knowing this project is
bigger than yourself
[Music]
after the casket arrives in the capital
rotunda but before the doors are open to
the public there will be a ceremonial
wreath presentation attended by Vice
President Mike Pence and McCain's 106
year old mother
Roberta Nancy thanks CBS News will bring
you live coverage of this morning's
ceremony for Senator McCain at the
Capitol rotunda beginning around 10:30
Eastern 9:30 central that's right here
on CBS you know be nice to see McCain's
mother Roberta McCain she's a hundred
and six years old as you said she had a
twin sister Rowena who passed away but
she's just also an incredible woman it's
really not until not long ago she used
to travel Europe with her sister ran a
car and go drive across Europe yes Ron
geez it's very strong genes